Hello Freak bitches,
fascinating about the liquid around them
out anyway,
but I suppose people that are signed
totally,
she would say this is our religion and
uh,
you're,
you're taking the piss out of our
religion.
It's an ideology that is also a very
positive one in the sense that it's
dedicated towards self improvement and
eliminating all these psychological
barriers that are holding you back and
in that way.
But people find a lot of benefit in
being a part of that religion.
And I think when they find a lot of
benefit in being a part of it,
then you know,
they could justify all the other
nonsense and just sort of ignore it.
Because what l Ron Hubbard,
according to the going clear book,
uh,
Lawrence Krauss book was trying to do
with self medicate would,
he had a lot of psychological issues
himself and he was trying to cure his
own issues and in using these methods to
cure his own religion or the zone,
his own issues,
he translated them into a religion.
Like this is a big part of what
scientology initially was,
was his own attempts to self diagnose
and treat his own psychological
ailments.
A good idea really works really well and
there are so I suppose people that it's
working for.
I like a quote,
I heard that I'd like to be quick to see
where religious people are.
Right.
You know,
it's all really obvious where religious
people are wrong.
You know,
cause we sort of hear about it on the
news but like where religious people to
write,
you know,
sort of togetherness,
selfless nurse relationship with a
deepest self acceptance of death and the
possibility of transcendence of the
human primal self.
Those things are all really beautiful
ideas.
They've kind of lost their way in a
science as scientists,
you know that term scientism,
the idea that sort of science has got
into territories that science company
handled because we come to a judge
during full stop at certain points.
You know like what happened on the
Tuesday before the Big Bang,
you know,
materialism,
individualism are hard things to
overcome.
If like if,
if people,
if we are,
if we have as our dominant mindset,
I'm only going to believe shit that I
can prove.
Then you are just an individual and you
may as well just,
you know,
why not just spend your life fucking as
many people as you can and accumulating
as much material as you can because
nothing exists unless you can see it,
measure it,
way it,
contain it and fuck it.
You know,
if that is the dominant belief system,
which we sort of materialism,
consumerism,
capitalism,
I think all dovetail on that premise.
You know,
this is all,
it's real fucked.
You know,
that's how you can have that chronic
ecological disrespect is because,
oh,
it doesn't matter what happens after
you're dead.
They'll be like,
well,
what about my fucking children?
Even just on a practical level of God
live on this fucking pebble in infinite
space.
And they'd like,
but if you're just like,
well no,
we've not really thought about that.
And a sort of an inability to accept,
you know,
like certain,
and I know that you're sort of like a,
I don't wholesale by any dominant
theory,
but I think it's clear to me that,
do you know what I believe in on an
individual level and on a cultural
level,
if something is possible,
you should be trying to fucking do it.
So as soon as people realize,
hold on a minute,
that's having a negative impact or hey,
this is a bit of a way of using our
resources.
Now utilities,
as soon as you realize it,
you should be moving towards it.
They say wisdom is acting on knowledge.
Why don't you even recognize our fossil
fuels are running out?
Is that right?
Fucking it all.
We'd better start working on the basis
that we're fucked.
We better start looking at alternative
energy stores is where look at different
alliances.
You just say like knowing those things
and not doing them,
it makes me very,
very uneasy because it makes me think
who benefits from ignoring this stuff?
Who's running this show?
If he's having all of that,
you know,
if it's creating all this rage,
all this unease,
all this fear in your country and in my
country now times of great,
great disease and uncertainty for people
really looking for something and know
that these institutions are just saying,
just,
you know,
carry on.
There's no sort of alternative.
No one's going to let you know.
No one now is going to see himself as
part of a religious community in the
same way or a sort of one of the dead
ideologies of the last century,
and meanwhile we're in this sort of
peculiar state of looming crisis that
feels kind of fucking mad.
Well,
we're definitely in a state of looming
crisis,
but to unpack this whole thing,
you started off with this idea of what
happened the Tuesday before the Big Bang
and how science can't really answer
that.
Well,
they can't answer it yet.
I did that.
The problem is once they gather more
data,
it might be a hundred years now or a
thousand years from now.
They can say,
Oh,
well here we've done the calculations
and we understand now that it's an
infinite cycle of birth and death and
the universe is constantly expanding and
contracting.
And this is the process that we're a
part of.
It's infinite and it's never started it,
it's never ending.
And it goes on and on and on.
Often you'll probably bloody right mate.
I like that idea that you just espoused
is in 5,000 year old fucking documents
called the upanishads.
Yeah.
Those are like,
those ideas are there already.
So when we fucked off religion a hundred
years ago,
because it was causing too much,
you know,
our sake,
we got,
we kicked out of some of the items that
are only now just being discovered,
right.
These are just to be contemplated right
now and to be considered where a science
is trying to find definitive evidence
that they do or don't represent the
reality of our timeline.
And once they do,
then they'll be able to talk about it.
But right now what they're doing is
they're examining the evidence that the
big bang exists and what could have
possibly caused that.
Yeah.
That,
see what my difficulty is is that there
are,
that is when any ideology behaves
dogmatically and prohibitively like
previous like prevents further
exploration,
whatever would like what kind of,
what's an example of the nature of
consciousness?
No one knows why consciousness impacts
matter in the way it does in the sub
quantum world.
No,
we can't fucking,
we've come to a point he's like,
oh fuck.
Like you know like if you would like
that,
that the famous double slit theory that
an observed particle behaves
differently,
like the end of the park on wave can
change it as the central nature
depending on where he's been obsessed
represented
though when it's been explained to me by
people actually understand it.
What it really is is that we're
measuring these particles and in the act
of measuring you're changing the
results.
Yeah.
Because you're using something to
measure it.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
But it gets represented as all this woo
woo craziness.
But what I think is interesting,
Joe,
is somewhere between this woowoo
craziness and that kind of a flat,
mundane,
low.
This is life.
You're born,
you die,
you eat food,
shit comes out your asshole territory.
Somewhere in there is a mystery that
they're behind your eyes buying Jimbo,
Jamie's eyes and my eyes.
There is a constant,
there is this consciousness,
there is this awareness.
There's this inexplicably experience
that you've add on dmt experiences that
I've had through yoga and through lsd.
That suggests to me that consciousness
itself is the dominant force.
Consciousness is not just one more
phenomena is the seat of all phenomena
and when people are saying,
oh,
there's this thing,
that's God.
What they are saying is there is an
absolute consciousness and all is
contained within it.
All matter at some point has come from
consciousness.
These realms,
they're experienced,
true psychedelic or extreme extreme,
you know,
personal experiments like your cryogenic
things or your flotation tanks all
suggest a phenomenon beyond the
individual consciousness.
They something else there and the very
fact that it's in for the,
the consciousness,
even by the process of measuring,
even by the process of measuring is
influencing and impacting rally.
I don't think that,
you know,
I'm not taking that to the extreme so I
know what you mean.
Make some people go,
oh that means your mind can control
shit.
I'm going,
I think it means that it means that
reality is only reality when you look at
it.
That's when it's kind of getting towards
a bloody good book that I reckon your
listeners will be banging into is called
buyer centuries in by a man called
Robert Lanza who he did the best
breakdown I've ever read of that double
slit experiment and a and of the,
the,
you know,
made me understand for the first time
that reality is happening within your
own consciousness.
It's not an external phenomena at all
that,
you know,
like Hebrew explained in very ways that
I could understand of like he went,
you know,
you sort of think,
thinks I'm totally mundane.
He went like,
you know the experience of going in your
kitchen in the night and turn in the
light on.
Is your kitchen fridge still there when
you go back downstairs?
He goes,
well,
I guess when you do go in your kitchen
in turn the light on,
he goes see a foa on parcels of photons
come down,
they'd interact with the optic nerve,
they re trends low,
they invert eating your consciousness.
You Go,
yeah.
So whatever it is,
it's in your kitchen.
When you're not looking at it,
it ain't the same as when you are
looking at is an interpretive reality.
And one of the ways that I've sort of
reduced this down for my own simple
understanding is this,
that if none of us had a sense of smell,
if you didn't,
I then Jamie didn't.
And then well how would the concept of
smell makes sense?
How would you go up?
There's paint,
there's bacon with,
none of us would have the instrument to
receive it.
So that whole thing would be off the
agenda.
So I think that there are streams of
energy streams of data for which we do
not have the instruments to receive.
So we totally it because we simply don't
have the instruments to receive it.
And I said once it in most startup,
as a matter of fact,
like yeah,
my cat doesn't know there's an internet.
The internet does not enter the realm of
my cats consciousness,
but the fucking internet is out there.
We're out here having with these fucking
experiences and like all those realms
that we're experiencing in these various
sort of psychedelic states or you know,
however they were achieved is an
indication to me there's another reality
now,
where does that become fucking relevant
to what we're talking about?
For me,
where it does,
he's one of the continual ideas that
keeps remerge reemerging to connect us
back to where we were with Joe Campbell
at the beginning is there is this
fucking sense of oneness and believing
ourselves to be individual and believing
that the dominant thing in our lives to
be material that fucks us up because
people will kill each other over that
material.
And once we sort of realized,
no,
we're,
the true thing about us is the
consciousness is the inner self.
That's the roofing.
They were all out here.
We're all in the game.
We're all going to do shit and we're all
gonna make mistakes.
But that's not have the material idea as
the dominant social idea cause that
everyone's agreed with that,
whether they're communist or capitalist
or fascist or whatever everyone's
saying.
Now the main thing is this shit this out
here.
And it's like that connects to those
primal drives.
Cause we know that if that's happening
in your sexual drive,
you can never have enough pussy.
If that gets into your status drive,
you can never have enough space and
power.
You know,
so like we're all going to still feel
those things.
I'm still going to be a 25 times a day,
but it'd be nice if the cultural
ambiance was,
oh don't worry Russell,
you'll be back to your normal self in a
minute of feeling that we're all one and
we're all connected,
not,
yeah.
Well of course I feel like that and
that's what frightens me about the
culture of our countries at the moment
is it's endorsing the worst aspects of
our nature.
It's a culturating the worst aspects of
our nature instead of the best aspects
of our nature.
And that for me then no fucking
difference between left and right in the
current political sphere because they're
all making the same argument.
They were all saying come and live out
here in the material world.
Yeah.
It seems to me that the material world
and this idea that we should be
accumulating possessions and status and
all these different things is universal.
It almost seems like it's a natural
progression from ancient tribal
civilization life to this weird city
life to this integration of electronics
and our life in this symbiotic
relationship that we have to computers
and the Internet and information itself.
It seems like this is one of the things
that drives,
that is this desire for material
possessions because when you have a
desire for material possessions and
ensures that you're going to continue to
innovate and come up with newer and
greater and better because you always
want to keep up with the Jones' is you
always want to have the newest tesla
cause it goes zero to 60 in two seconds
and you want to have the coolest fucking
house with the biggest TV and the
fastest internet and all those things
sort of compound this technological
innovation cycle that we're on.
So my thought has been for a long time
that what we are is some sort of
electronic caterpillar that's going to
give birth some artificial life and that
all of our desire for material
possessions and status and all these
different things is really just us
pushing for this electronic agenda and
that this innovation and the
construction of artificial intelligence
that's inevitable is eventually going to
be the next stage of life.
And that word like huddling ourselves up
in this sort of civilization cocoon and
that boom,
out of that cocoon is going to pop some
sort of a god being and that this is
what we're here for and this is what
we've been doing since we're a monkey's
flinging shit at each other and flipping
over cow patties,
looking for mushrooms,
that we are a part of a process and then
if you look at it objectively,
all these traps that you or I or Tom
Cruise or Jim breuer been caught up in
when whether it's traps of ego or
jealousy,
all these things sort of ensure
movement.
They insure movement and ensure
interactivity and that is going to
ensure innovation and progress and
competition and all those things that
even we look at it,
we go,
this is so pointless.
This is so foolish,
but yet it's so incredibly prevalent.
Not Glorifying it or saying it's
definitely the way to go,
but objectively,
if you weren't a human and you're
stepping outside of this thing,
looking at it from a distance,
you're like,
these fuckers are making something.
They might not even know they're making
something.
That's they're making concern just hand
out the same way that bees or ants may
not be aware of their hive consciousness
and that and the common drive.
But where I disagree with you Joe,
is that,
that you see the end point as being the
materialization of a superconsciousness
through technology.
I see the end point is being a
realization amongst us as a species.
Now I know that they're now,
it could be both and there is no,
you know,
there is no reason to,
uh,
you know,
we are just another fucking,
are we just another species on this
planet?
Oh,
we will know better than dogs and cows
and monkeys.
I don't,
I,
you know,
how can,
how certain we are,
if the path,
the very sun that heats us up has a
lifespan.
Yeah.
Where are their inventions as well?
The cats and the monkeys.
There's,
I'm fuck they invented being cute.
I mean,
they're the real darling in your lap.
You pet them.
They need to find contribution
contributing cause the dog for a walk.
You come up with good ideas,
whereas smelly.
That's fair.
That's fair enough.
I do love my dog bear,
but hold on.
Uh,
but my,
what was my,
what was my point there?
God
breaks.
What you're saying is we should pump the
brakes,
we should pump the brakes of this
possession and this,
this idea that we're trying to
accomplish these great things by
accumulating things and status and it's
all bullshit and it's really about
consciousness more than anything.
In fact,
Bill Hicks I think already said it when
he said that,
you know,
that we,
we can be explicit,
we can explore space in a,
an hour together and peace.
Not that,
that idea that if we look to our common
drives,
it's like into that hancock all the
time.
I've heard him on your show saying like
that,
you know,
that what really what's happening is a
bias towards a particular aspect of our
own consciousness.
The problem solving brain and like,
you know,
there's no,
that those drives are amazing,
but those jobs,
they're trying to get somewhere.
Technology is amazing.
We were like,
you know,
at the very fact that people bloody here
is,
I don't understand any of it.
It's fucking wonderful.
But the dominant idea behind it,
one of profit,
that dominating idea and like in a
profit in itself is not necessarily
negative,
but profit at all costs.
[inaudible] costs.
So like really,
I'm not saying we should as a species
fucking slow down and dressing felon
fucking,
you know,
like Graham and vegetables,
funny.
Now I want human beings to be glorious.
But what I'm saying is that our bias
towards this one particular I'm
materialistic idea is preventing us from
realizing that glory because part of our
consciousness has been ignored.